[Musique]
j'aimerais commencer cette présentation
par une euh un exercice
attendez j'ai un message c'est
important ah mais c'est un nouveau
follower sur Instagram TikTok aussi cool
c'est un de 1950 c'est presque 3000 on y
arrive alors
euh j'étais où j'en étais où j'ai même
pas commencé et je suis déjà
interrompu bref pour commencer je vous
propose une expérience de faire ensemble
sortez vos téléphones de vos poches s'il
vous plaît mais ne faites
rien garde-le comme
ça surtout ne le déverrouillez pas
il est beau hein
hein qu'est-ce que ça sent qu'est-ce que
vous
ressentez avez-vous aussi cette envie
incroyable de de vérifier si vous avez
reçu un message une notification en
WhatsApp si quelqu'un s'intéresse à
vous vous savez c'est ça qu'on appelle
l'effet slot machine et nos téléphone
était de développer avec cette effet en
tête en psychologie on parle de
renforcement
intermittent à tout moment quelque chose
d'intéressant d'excitant pourrait
apparaître sur nos écrans mais on sait
pas exactement quand comment cela va se
passer cela déclenche dans notre cerveau
de la dopamine c'est le
neurotransmetteur de du plaisir de la
bonheur de
l'excitation c'est pour ça qu'on est si
tenté de de contrôler nos nos téléphones
en
permanence et même un téléphone étant
déclâ dans not cerveau de la dopamine
parce que entre-temps quelque chose
d'excitant pourrait se
passer mais pourquoi je vous raconte
tout ça parce que je constate qu'on est
tous à Croix nos
téléphones regardez dans les bus sur les
train table à Noël ou pour certains à
table tous les
jours
même s'il y a pas une définition
clinique de l'addiction numérique de la
dépendance au digitale il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de recherche qui se fait dans
le domaine
malheureusement malheureusement la
plupart de la recherche vient des
États-Unis et c'est pas encore très
connu ici en Suisse je
trouve mais si vous la lisez c'est
effrayante les conséquences que notre
addition euh notre utilisation
compulsive des smartphones à sur nos sur
nous joue au niveau
cognitive la capacité d'apprendre euh de
se concentrer la mémoire au niveau
psychologique au niveau comportemental
et même au niveau
physique je vous fais quelques
exemples déjà avant la pandémie euh Jean
tenger de l'université de San Diego en
Californie a fait des études pour nous
montrer comment une génération entière
ce qu'elle appelle
en high generation après l'aîné après
l'année
2000 préfère passer beaucoup plus de
temps à la maison collé à leurs écrans
dans le mond sûr et confortable des
relations virtuelles
elle ne sort
plus ne pas sortir ça veut dire moins
d'activité physique moins de sport
moins de vrais amis moins de rencontres
moins de relations sociales on peut le
mesurer même par moins de
rapport vous avez
compris moins de vraie vie en réalité en
anglais il a même une expression pour
dire on se voit en vraie vie real life
on se voitl
demain de plus en plus de gens se disent
seul isolé sans
amis même si peut-être ils ont 3000
followers sur Instagram sur Instagram
comme moi ou 2000 amis sur
facebook le taux de suicide chez les
jeunes filles a triplé dans les
dernières 10
années les effets que les réseaux
sociaux ont sur l'apparence l'image de
soi les standard de beauté c'est
simplement catastrophique pour toutes
générations
très intéressant les études nous
montrent aussi que plus de temps on pas
sur les écrans en général moins on est
capable de nous concentrer de penser à
profondeur ce que les Anglais appellent
deep
thinking même de ressourre des problèmes
on ne fait que chercher la solution sur
Google et on entraî pas la
mémoire nous nous entraînons à être
constantement interrompu par des
notifications qui nous bombardent
partout et notre capacité d'attention
plonge et peut-être le plus
important on n'arrive plus à faire une
seule chose à la fois on fait semblant
d'être multitach quand les neurosciences
nous ont déjà expliqué que le
multitasking c'est un vieux mythe
n'existe pas notre cerveau ne fait rien
d'autre que switcher entre deux
plusieurs tâches et ça c'est extrêmement
fatiguant
dans en fin de journée vous êtes fatigué
c'est souvent parce que on a fait
beaucoup de
multitaches donner un une tablette ou un
smartphone un enfant ça veut dire lui
apprendre à être constantement distrait
interrompu euh isolé
fatigué et je parle même pas de de ce
que la science nous dit maintenant sous
les conséquences euh sous l'empathie
l'image de soi les résultats scolaires
la
créativité ils ont fait plusieurs études
ils ont mis de deux classes une classe
étudie papier la même sujet qu' deème
classe qui étudie sur tablette ou sur
ordinateur et toujours les étudiants qui
étudient sur papier ont des meilleurs
résultats au même test toujours mais
nous
disp les enfants on ont pas besoin
d'écan pour grandir au contraire ils ont
besoin de toute notre attention parce
qu'ils emprend en nous regardant et
ça ça va
pas autrefois les bonnes manières nous
dicté queon lit pas son journal la table
n'est-ce pas aujourd'hui sorti son
téléphone c'est presque normal la
table mais c'est une question de taille
c'est juste plus
petit voilà et le message est le même je
fais autre chose je suis intéressé à
quelque chose d'autre je suis ailleurs
il y a quelque chose plus intéressant
que
toi j'adore celle-ci hein vous l'avez vu
très
romantique
bref mesdames et messieurs je pense que
si nous soutionons du monde si nous
soutionons de la prochaine génération de
ceux qui son en train de devenir
maintenant adulte et ceux qui son encore
loin à venir nous ne pouvons tout
simplement pas continuer comme ça
révons-nous d'un monde on est tous
esclav de la
technologie moi je dis
non moi je dis osons revenevenir
redevenir maître de notre temps et de
notre esprit maintenant pourquoi je
parle de temps et
d'esprit vous pourrez me dire mais Mario
on a tous le libre arbitre chacun est
libre de choisir comment passer son
temps le problème c'est qu'on n'est pas
vraiment libre l'industrie
multimilliardaire des réseaux sociaux et
des géants de web font tout mais tout ce
qu'ils peuvent pour nous rendre à cro et
nous manipuler parce que leur vrai
business model au début c'était de nous
mettre en contact de créer des relations
globales magnifique mais maintenant
c'est fait de l'argent avec notre temps
et notre esprit notre attention ils
veulent capturer tous nos attentions et
plus capturent plus ils ont des données
pour nous cibler avec de la publicité on
dit un effet qu'on a qu'on habite on est
dans le temps de l'attention economy
l'économie de la
tension je vous fais un exemple on va se
faire un selfie vous êtes d'accord vous
pas pour la privac on fait
Simp
alors jeis quand même photo vous êtes
prêts vous êtes tout attends voilà comme
ça c'est 1 2
3 top alors je le
poste hash
texb hash so cool
bref enant ces photos c un nouveau
follower génial enant ces photos il faut
être
conscient que je donne mon consement à
ce image cette image et T un nouveau
follower cette image et tous les
informations qui viennent avec soi
utilisé pour de la publicité ciblé et
vendu vendu
utilisé comment ça marche plus de temps
on passe sur les réseaux sociaux sur
Internet plus eux ils ont de
l'information pour nous cibler et c'est
pour ça qu'on a poussé à passer plein de
temps et tout ce qu'on partage nos
habitudes de vie nos goûts nos likes euh
c'est c'est tout de l'information très
utile le New York Times une fois s'est
amusé à calculer qu'on dépense chaque
jour que sur facebook collectivement
40 40000 presque 40000 années
d'attention chaque jour toute une
attention du temps et de l'esprit qui
pourra être consacré à faire autre chose
je
pense je fais encore un autre exemple
pour comprendre un peu mieux comment ça
marche les publicitaires ça le savent
très bien autrefois on supposait qu'une
femme entre 25 et 35 ans aurait un bon
probabilité de tomber enceinte donc
avoir besoin de ces produits là on
faisait de la publicité donc pas trop
bien ciblé dans la presse spécialisée
chez les professionnel les placardes les
grandes
surfaces aujourd'hui si je suis un
fabricant de ces produits je fais
beaucoup mieux à payer Google et
Facebook pour qu'il m'aide à cibler
exactement tous les femmes qui par
exemple dans les derniers mois ont posté
des photos de leur ventre ou des photos
de bébés je peux faire très bien
ça et vous savez combien les entreprises
ont dépensé dans les dernières
années sur le groupe méta donc Facebook
Instagram et
WhatsApp
113 milliards 113000 millions 113
milliards de dollars publicité dans le
groupe
metta et sur Google
225 milliards de
dollars c'est la publicité les Google
Ads qui qui font remonter dans les dans
les recherches les premiers résultats
souvent c'est
payantes en attendant changement de
business model ou peut-être en
législation qu'est-ce que pouvons-nous
faire personnellement à la naissance de
mon fils Lucas j'en avais marre de
recevoir de la publicité pour nouveaux
pères et j'aiffacé T Mones compes des
réseaux sociaux mais attention il faut
pas être aussi radical que moi et tout
effacé il y a selon moi des gestes des
actions quotidiennes qu'on peut intégrer
dans notre vie et qui nous aide à
contrôler un peu plus nos téléphones
avant que soit eux à nous
contrôler laissez mooi vous donner cinq
suggestions la première c'est
oser
remarquez et mesurer quand où et combien
de temps vous passez sur vos téléphone
il y a par exemple s plein de téléphones
l'utille tant d'écran qui vous aide à
faire
ça souvent si au début de journée je
vous demande combien de temps vous avez
intention de passer ce jour-là sous vos
téléphone en finin de journeré c'est
beaucoup
plus 2è
osez prendre des rendez-vous avec
vous-même il faut pas de la méditation
ou de yoga compliqué nécessairement ça
suffit de lire un livre en papier de
temps en temps ou passer simplement
d'outant
seul avec ses
pensées ça fait très bien ça fait du
bien tout ce que nous fait
euh reconncter à nos émotions notre
cerveau notre
cœur c'est très bien pour la créativité
aussi tr è et vous me mettez c'est une
petite liste
osez conduire sans regarder vos écrans
25 % 1/4 de tous les accidents de la
route sont aujourd'hui causés par un
téléphone au volant
osez vous
promener sans regarder vos téléphone et
taper vous risquez de perdre quelque
chose d'intéressant autour de vous de
faire une belle rencontre et en plus
c'est dangereux
je pense vous l'avez bien compris osez
partager un repas sans sortir vos
téléphone tout de suite
osez étendre vos
téléphone au moins 1 heure avant d'aller
au lit on sait que ça améliore le
sommeil et
allons-y ça tue tout un intimité
romantisme si vous avez besoin d'un
réveil vous en achetez un ça coûte moins
de 10
francs 4e
osz être des utilisateurs actifs
osez contrôler vos applications et vos
notifications je suis sûr que vous avez
plein d'applications inutiles sur votre
téléphone vous les effacez et plein de
notifications qui vous en bête vous
bombarde tout la journée vous allez dans
dans paramètrre notification oFF oFF oFF
c'est beaucoup plus facile que vous
pensez l'important c'est nous qui on
décide quand voir quoi et quoi faire
avec nos téléphone et pas
eux et finalement
osez de temps en temps oubliez vos
téléphone laissez-le à la maison rien va
se passer et profitons de la nature de
notre famille des gens qu'on
aime merci beaucoup et bon
courage